this summer peter parker's returning to
the big screen in spider-man homecoming
the immensely popular character has been
through a lot over the last couple of
decades here's what's changed since the
webslinger first flew over the New York
skyline spider-man was introduced in
comics in 1962 and first popped up on
television in a short-lived CBS series
called The Amazing Spiderman in 1977 a
couple of films were released overseas
using footage that was recut from the TV
series after that a new spider-man movie
spent two decades and development have
multiple movie studios finally after a
legal battle between MGM and Sony over
rights to the character the two
companies settled and Sony went into
production in 2000 with Sam Raimi
directing and Tobey Maguire starring his
fight the first spider-man was released
in 2002 and was a critical and
commercial smash hit it was the first
movie ever to make over a hundred
million dollars in its opening weekend
it also helped pave the way for
superhero movies to take over Hollywood
the sequel
spider-man 2 was another critical in
box-office smash the franchise's woes
started to take hold in 2007 while
spider-man 3 was no box-office bomb it
fared poorly with critics and audiences
and the studio decided to cancel
spider-man for just five years later
Sony rebooted with the amazing
spider-man starring Andrew Garfield it
was another origin story but this time
they went back to spider-man's roots and
let him build his own web blasters which
was a nice touch reminding us all what a
genius the Peter Parker character is
supposed to be the follow-up the amazing
spider-man 2 was a critical and
commercial disappointment and Sony
quickly canceled plans for a third one
and also delayed plans for several
spider-man universe spin-offs including
the sinister six and venom with so many
other giant superhero blockbusters and
franchises things were looking rough for
spider but in an unprecedented deal
between Sony and Disney spider-man was
allowed to cross over into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the new spy team
played by newcomer Tom Holland stole the
show in Captain America Civil War for
the first time it really felt like
spider-man was
like the teenager he is even better
Holland actually was a teenager when he
first donned the spandex suit as opposed
to Maguire and Garfield who were both in
their late twenties when they played the
role subgun wait a minute you guys are
the real Avengers I can tell hope gives
it away
spider-man homecoming looks and feels
more like a Marvel film than anything
Sony has done before
especially with the heavy use of Tony
Stark Stark design Spidey suit and it
looks like it's going to be full of Iron
Man like tricks and gadgets will
homecoming finally be a return to form
for the webslinger we'll find out in
July what do you think about the latest
spider-man trailer who's your favorite
spider-man let us know in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]